so the drama in the banking sector the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank has a
lot of Americans concerned about how to
protect their money and of course
politicians are using that concern to
their advantage as always several states
are now trying to centralize currency
with these so-called Central Bank
digital currency which is by the way not
currency at all it's software
but they're going to do it for your own
good obviously this is a tool of total
social control if they control your
money if they can zero out your bank
account with a keystroke then you have
no autonomy they control you
well in the state of South Dakota
legislators just passed a bill that
would have changed the definition of
money to exclude cryptocurrency and that
would put the state on a path to
centralized digital currency
South Dakota's Governor Christie gnome
the only Governor we're aware of was
paying attention to this vetoed that
bill she joins us tonight to explain why
Governor thank you very much for doing
this first and for coming on
um why did you do it you're obviously
Under Pressure not to veto it but you
did why did you
well Tucker was the right thing to do I
became aware of this bill it wasn't
introduced until almost halfway through
our legislative session we started
reading through this bill that was over
110 pages long it was sold as an update
to the guidelines of the universal
Commercial Code backed by all of our
financial institutions our banks as we
started reading through it we saw the
section of the bill that changed the
definition of currency and essentially
what it did was pave the way for a
government-led
cbdc and it also banned any other form
of cryptocurrency or Bitcoin or digital
currency that existed so for me it very
clearly was a threat to our freedom in
South Dakota we are the session that
completes its business earliest in the
year we are the first ones to really
look at this bill and find out the truth
of what's in it and I did veto that bill
I'm asking my legislators to change
their minds to make the right decision
and help me kill this bill once and for
all but I'm telling you Tucker here
we've got the same language coming to
over 20 other states I believe it's to
pave a way for the federal government to
control our currency and thus control
people it should be alarming to everyone
and it's being sold as a UCC guidelines
update there's no rush to do this we
need to be smart and make sure that
we're doing what we can to protect
people I find it ironic that we also are
having this discussion at the same time
we have Banks and credit card companies
talking about coding gun and ammunition
in a separate code so they can track it
so not only can they tie these two
issues together if the government
doesn't approve of what you're
purchasing if they have the only form of
digital currency out there and that is
endorsed and utilized in the country
they can control how you spend that
money and thus take away all your
freedom
so nicely put and I and I don't think
you're overstating at all the
significance of this really quickly do
you think and you want to give everyone
the benefit of the doubt on their
motives but do you think that
legislators in your state understand
what this bill was actually designed to
do
yeah I don't know if they read it
Tucker that's what is alarming to me is
it was over 110 pages long and they were
told by lobbyists that they had listened
to for the last 20 years that it's fine
it's just a regulation update this is
what we do is adopt Federal Regulations
but if you start reading it you see in
there there is a redefinition of
currency that it says government cbdc's
are okay if they're run by the
government but any other form is then
banned it is clearly a change for how
people's assets are utilized it clearly
limits the freedom of people to use
other forms of currency that they may
choose to if it is a digital currency
and it is clearly putting power into the
hands of government I think anything we
should have learned the last several
years is the government can't be trusted
uh you know Bill Tucker what I was
surprised by was that you know the bills
that have made it to my desk this year
people think about South Dakota being
conservative and being a very Republican
state the first bill I had to veto was a
tax increase now this has made it to my
desk we've got other challenges as well
I really hope that we've done inspires
other Governors appreciate your coming
on tonight Governor Christie gnome of
South Dakota thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight